hello
and welcome to sherlock holmes chapter
one an open world action investigation
game that explores the first steps of
sherlock becoming the world's greatest
detective
you are sherlock a 21 year old aspiring
private eye who struggles to prove
himself to the world
before you lies cordona an exotic island
under a british protectorate in the
mediterranean sea
don't expect a warm welcome here most
folks are prejudiced against foreigners
especially those who are well dressed
and easy on the eyes
that makes your job as a rookie
detective even more complicated
whether you're vaccinated or not
sherlock holmes chapter 1 won't hold
your hand as you investigate cordona's
darkest secrets
it's up to you to find your way around
the island and to decide what your next
step will be
in this video we want to give you a
glimpse at the seemingly elegant
paradise
and more importantly the tools that you
will have at your disposal to analyze
your environment and blend in
let us also briefly take a look at the
island itself we designed it to be as
varied as possible
with five unique districts for the
player to explore
each area offers fascinating vistas
colorful
characters and new side quests the old
city district is an area mostly
populated by the ottoman descendants
its architectural styles are influenced
by eastern and southern european
cultures
giant fortress walls famous turkish
bathhouses
the bazaar and the caravan sarai hotel
make it the tourist mecca
the scaladio district is a bustling
administrative center
mostly controlled by the british empire
this area is as european as it gets
with city hall cathedrals museums banks
and hotels all built by the venetians in
the before times
here is grand sarai an uptown district
lined with
opulent villas and luxurious
establishments
it's a popular exotic vacation destined
for the rich
[Music]
then we have miner's end the poorest
district on the island
it is a shanty area an abandoned silver
mine with decrepit buildings and slums
and last we have silverton an industrial
district
full of factories and warehouses some
intact
some abandoned rest assured
each and every one of those districts
will treat you like a stranger most
people won't take you seriously
you sure you're in the right place we
don't serve cocktails here
i'm looking for information about a
sailor who recently drowned in
scallardio
would you happen to know anything about
him maybe maybe not
why would i talk to a landlubber about
it hey in order to get closer to your
suspects and gain their trust
you will need to change your overall
appearance and how you act this is where
our new disguise mechanic comes in handy
what can i get you mate nah i'm good
don't want to end up like that guy who
drowned in the fountain after having one
too many throughout the game
new outfits can be purchased from
vendors or earned by completing quests
across the island
there are dozens of outfits hats facial
accessories and cosmetic items at your
disposal
use them to customize your sherlock to
your liking and role-play as a senior
policeman
local trader or even a pirate to get
into closed-off areas
sneak into the police's prison cells or
private venues as you pursue the truth
of cordona's weirdest transgressions
however while many situations require a
specific outfit
it's only a piece of the puzzle as a
stranger on the island
you will need to approach its citizens
and ask for help
there are several social classes within
the game like aristocrats
workers lowlifes and etc
knowing who to approach what questions
to ask and how to disguise yourself is
key to getting the job done
every item you select for your disguise
will have to be accurate enough to give
you credibility overall
so that each class is more likely to
take you seriously and want to share
information with you
ah it's you i mean
it's him it's him keep in mind
everyone on the island will react to
your new identity either positively or
negatively
asking intel from a policeman while
dressed as a thug will get you nowhere
but put on an aristocratic outfit and
some will give you the world
in order to check the potential reaction
of someone use the concentration mode
all the people of cordona have three
different default labels that will help
you gain an overall view of who they are
first is ethnicity and occupation second
is dynamic and will change according to
the person
and your current disguise the third is a
specific trait of this person
all cordonians are unique and you'll
have to adapt to them to find your way
through the island's mysteries
let me give you an example we're on the
hunt for a mermaid
apparently there's someone going around
killing sailors and the locals believe
it's a water nymph
while this sounds preposterous we still
need to find the culprit
so where would be the right place to
start let's choose to head to the local
saloon that the sailors frequent and
talk to the bartender
the issue is all we know is the saloon's
name but its whereabouts are sort of on
the hush hush
we can ask one of the sailors about it
but they are unlikely to talk to some
fancy pants rich boy
so here's how i'm going to approach the
situation
i'm going to buy a sailor's outfit and
put it on then
i'm going to open up my casebook select
and pin the right evidence
the one that mentions the name of the
saloon with this piece of evidence
pinned
i can approach people on the streets and
ask them if they know something about it
since i'm dressed appropriately i'm more
likely to get a reply
so as you can see we aim to create
gameplay elements that synergize with
one another
and give you engaging tools that are fun
to use at the same time
we leave it up to you to discover the
synergy and think about how
and when you want to apply it
after all what makes a great detective
is your intuition
and that's what we want to engage we
want you to use your
gut feeling and follow what your
intuition says
sherlock holmes chapter 1 is coming to
pc playstation 5
xbox series x and last gen platforms
sometime in 2021
if you like what you're seeing consider
wish listing the game on the platform of
your choice
and subscribe to our social media for
more news and gameplay
thanks for watching our video i'll see
you in the next one
you